When you watch a major motion picture, you'd
never imagine that a huge production would
make any last-minute decisions.
Or if they did, it would surely be over something
small, not something that could drastically
change the movie forever.
But really, the opposite is true.
Some of your favorite films were within in
an inch of turning out terrible, if it wasn't
for a last-second change that made these movies
into what they are today.
Toy Story
Before Toy Story became a classic of computer
animation, it was almost a mean-spirited cartoon
about a jerky cowboy doll that everyone hated.
Jeffrey Katzenberg, Disney's CEO at the time,
had wanted this cartoon in a new medium to
be as edgy as possible.
Eager to please, the Pixar folks pushed the
meanness to the max and hoped it was going
in the right direction.
When they screened the first part of the film,
no one could believe the results.
It was just a story about mean, hateful toys.
There was no fun and nothing lovable.
In this version, Woody intentionally tosses
Buzz out the window.
Then, the toys revolt against him and throw
him out the window to his own doom.
Even director John Lasseter couldn't believe
how bad it was.
"I was pretty much embarrassed with what was
on the screen."
The result: the execs wanted Lasseter to fire
a bunch of people and start animating under
Disney's direct supervision.
He refused, and asked for two weeks to make
it work.
Disney allowed it and, after working all hours
and disregarding all the previous notes, the
Pixar team was able to present enough of the
revised Toy Story to keep their jobs and keep
going with the film.
In the end, the story was completely retooled
and became the wonderful movie we all love
today.
Zootopia
In its original form, Zootopia hardly resembled
the film we know now.
First of all, Judy Hopps wasn't the main character.
Plus, all the predators had to wear shock
collars around their necks for their whole
lives.
If that sounds unpleasant, don't worry, the
Zootopia filmmakers agreed.
In the original script, once predators got
to a certain age, they'd have to put on their
taming collars for the first time.
Watching this happy little bear realize he'll
never be free again is heartbreaking.
Though Disney doesn't usually shy away from
heartbreak, the filmmakers eventually felt
the overall taming concept made the movie
too dark and unappealing.
So, they revamped the entire script, made
Judy the main character, and threw those collars
in the idea-garbage.
American Beauty
Before winning five Academy Awards, American
Beauty nearly had a different ending that
may have kept it out if the Oscars altogether.
In the first draft of the script, the story
is bookended by a court trial in which Lester's
daughter Jane and her boyfriend, Ricky, are
accused of shooting Lester.
The trial uses the tape they made where Jane
says she'd like Ricky to get rid of her dad
as the proof.
The film ends with Ricky and Jane getting
wrongfully convicted and sent to jail.
In the end, a last minute edit came to the
rescue.
"We shot all of that stuff, but, uh, luckily
Sam, you know in editing, sorta took it out."
Screenwriter Alan Ball agreed with the change,
feeling that the ending was too depressing.
That might sound strange for a film that already
ends with the main character getting shot,
but the innocent teens taking the blame was
a step too far.
Plus, it took away from Lester's main story,
so the wraparound was cut and Ricky and Jane
got to go free.
Shrek
The character of Shrek went through a lot
of changes before we ended up with the Scottish
ogre with a heart-of-gold.
Originally, Mike Myers recorded most of his
lines in a Canadian accent.
It was basically, Myers' own voice with a
bit of exaggeration.
But the actor felt it wasn't working right.
Inspired by the upper-class English accent
John Lithgow used for Lord Farquaad, Myers
felt Shrek should have a more working-class
sound.
He ended up settling on Scottish and insisted
on redoing all the lines with his new idea.
"Look, there's Bloodnut the Flatulent.
You can guess what he's famous for."
"Alright, now I KNOW you're making this up."
Unfortunately, the animators had already finished
a third of film, and the new voice required
a ton of changes.
In fact, Myers' choice to go Scottish cost
the film at least $4 million.
Clerks
Kevin Smith made a big splash with his independent
film debut, Clerks.
A black and white comedy about two aimless
men working at a convenience store, Clerks
set up characters that Smith would return
to for years to come.
Part of what makes Clerks great was its casual,
comedic dialogue and slice-of-life tone.
That all could have been ruined by the original
ending.
Originally, Dante, one of the Quick Stop workers,
gets shot in a robbery and the film ends right
after that.
Brian O'Halloran, the actor who played Dante
said, "I hated that ending.
I just thought it was too quick of a twist."
As it turned out, Smith wasn't married to
that finale either.
He shot it mostly because he wasn't sure what
to do to end the movie.
Luckily, he agreed with O'Halloran and went
with the non-tragic ending, where the simply
store closes for the evening, and life goes
on.
Terminator 2
The ending of Terminator 2 is, literally,
the most metal ending of all time: a robot
gets lowered into a vat of molten metal.
So imagine if, after that, the movie cuts
to a bright blue sky over a playground where
granny Sarah Connor is tying her cute little
grandchild's shoes.
That's originally how director James Cameron
wanted it to end.
In that ending, Judgment Day never happened,
John Connor is a senator, and Sarah is an
old lady with a drinking problem.
Thankfully, Cameron realized that this ending
was completely out of tone with the rest of
the film and would have ruined any chances
for sequels.
Or...maybe he finally saw the wisdom in the
Terminator's own words.
"It has to end here."
Nah.
It was totally about the sequels.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!